something had me intrigued I heard that
they don't inflate their tires with air
the mixture of nitrogen and oxygen
instead they remove the oxygen and stick
just nitrogen in the tires and I'm
thinking why we want the heat that's
created in the tire I believe the
nitrogen will be less affected by that
temperature and so this air is going to
increase as the tire gets hot gets
warmer the size of this tire we want to
minimize the change in that tire from
the moment it leaves Pit Road and goes
out on the racetrack and performs and so
they found a mixture that would be less
volatile less affected by temperature
foreign
[Music]